[Music]  i can't really be a lawyer and a  criminal can i  i want to win but do i want to win like  this  i'm of two minds here so it's a coin  flip  johnny vedi was murdered tonight falcone  crime family has to be taken down  there's only room for one homicidal  maniac in this town  why are you running you could use a  little fun  i thought you didn't hurt people  you thought wrong  you still haven't figured out who killed  johnny viti  a killer who only works on holidays  there's lots of crazy out there  once i take him out things are gonna be  different we can start a family  the city has fallen alfred and we must  endeavor to lift it up again  who is holiday and who's next  [Music]  you